do you remember the hardest time you've
laughed i i remember it yes i remember
the heart
i would i remember the hardest time i've
left um it was in uh it was i was a
young kid yeah and um i went to hebrew
day school and there was this really uh
dorky kid um
we'll call him ari because i don't
because we're on national television and
that's a universally jewish dorky name
um and uh ari um he was like the kind of
dirk that carried insulin in a pouch in
like a fanny pack
for his diabetes and he wore
as opposed to the cool ammo belt
or the
the camo pack where you can just put the
straw
just get your uh sugar through the straw
of your camo pack
and uh ari and he wore like those um
those prescription glasses that if they
were sunglasses they'd be aviators but
i'm getting a very vivid
but like because they're not sunglasses
they look like they fell off the guy
that molested him
i'll be taking these yeah
oh cool
you don't want these in no i'm good now
it's so dark it's so dark whatever
no one's gonna see them
um
so uh um
so uh ari also um
wore
everyday
air casts on his ankles which are um uh
i don't know if if they were a big thing
in like the late 80s early 90s in like
nurses offices and schools which is it
was basically like
you know a cast that did nothing it was
like it was it had velcro on it had like
air pockets on the side and he wore him
on both ankles
every day
like if he fell off a boat he'd be fine
yeah he well
you drown but they would find it
sorry
it drowned but didn't find it
so um
on april fool's me and a couple of my
other punk buddies were like uh let's
play a trick on
buddies of the hebrew day school
yeah it was not great yeah it was like
me and two other kids in beastie boys
shirts the leader of the cool jews yeah
there was no one cooler yeah um we
wanted to do this april fool's playing
for for our teacher and uh in hebrew day
schools they have like the craft section
in the in the room like there's no
division between like art class and you
know you just do everything in one class
and so at launch
um and recess everybody went out to play
recess and me and my punk group
ran inside and um clogged the sinks and
turned them on and we in our hey the
drain the drains and in our head we were
like this is gonna be
so hilarious like miss classifier's
gonna walk into the room her feet will
get wet we'll jump out of the closet
because we're gonna hide in the closet
and go april fool's and she'll be like
oh
you mensches
but um
instead what happened was we clogged the
drains we
hid in the in the coat closet the door
to the classroom opened
and ari walked in wait there's water
everywhere oh it's soaked the whole
floor is like soaked there's like three
feet of water we like really crank the
thing
and ari walked in and he did one of
those like he was talking to someone
he was talking to like someone outside
the door
i i have no i i don't know what they
were talking probably like pong or
something
you know or tamagotchis or whatever
you know and he was like yeah yeah i'll
have my mom come drop me off and then he
turned around he did like and he's like
okay all right bye phone
legs in the air he landed
on his back and like if you took a
picture above it would look like it when
a body falls in a build off a building
from
like
you know like in naked gun movies when
the body hits the ground and like an arm
is here and a leg is like back there
and they like do the chalk outline or
whatever and the guy's like oh
he's screaming on the ground my ankles
my weak ankles
my ankle you specified my weak angle the
angles that i cast with air
and actually now that you bring it up i
remember when we walked over the air
casts had fallen off but we're floating
that's the hardest i've ever laughed